WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY AND
THEN THE LITTLE CLOSER TO
COOL, EVERYBODY.
IT IS THE HOT SPOT IN TOWN
SERVING SERVING ELEVATED FOOD,
AN ASTOUNDING COCKTAILS. AND
NOW A NIGHT FOR ALL OF YOU WHY
LOVERS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CASSIE DETAILS AT VIRGIN
HOTELS, LAS VEGAS AND JOINING
ME IS THE GENERAL MANAGER
ABOUT THE RESTAURANT AND WE'RE
JUST TALKING OFF THE AIR IT IS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS INSIDE
TELL US ABOUT THE FAIR AND THE
RBA.
SO COASTAL ITALIAN WERE
PART OF THE ISSUE HERE YOU MAY
KNOW SOMEWHERE PROPERTIES IN
LA AS WELL. YEAH OF COURSE,
THE ITALIAN WE HAVE A GREAT
OWN JOE FOR PETE SAYS. FRESH
WHOLE FISH REALLY IS GREAT AND
NOW YOU'RE SPECIAL WINE I SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE A
A LITTLE LESSON FROM ME
HERE TALK ABOUT THE Y NIGHT
THAT YOU'RE DOING IT'S ON
MONDAYS WHAT'S IT CALLED SO
CALLED THE LOVE YOU KNOW FROM
04:00PM TILL WE CLOSE MONDAY
NIGHT HALF-PRICED BOTTLES OF
WINE FOR ALL LOCAL, SO.
WHETHER THE BIG BOY OVER
HERE, OKAY MISTER SAUCE A CAR
SUS, A COYOTE OR ANY OF OUR
HIGH IN FRENCH WINES
EVERYTHING IS IS HALF HALF OFF
NOW WE'VE GOT A NICE HERE
LET'S TALK ABOUT.
FIRST OF ALL I WAS JUST
SWIRLING LIKE I KNEW WHAT I
NO IDEA WHAT DO WE TELL US WHY
WORSE WHY WE SWIRL.
THE 2 MAIN REASONS ONE IS
REALLY TO CARRY THE WINE SO
YOU ALLOW THE AIR TO GET IN
THERE. SO YOU CAN. GET A GOOD
SMELL AN AROMA WHAT AM I GET
LOOKING FOR HERE SO FOR THIS
YOU'RE GOING TO SOME SOME
LIGHT FRUITS OS A LITTLE
BERRIES LITTLE BIT OF A CRISP
APPLE IN THERE AS WELL LITTLE
CITRUS A LITTLE LITTLE BIT OF
CITRUS FLEUR DE ROSE A FOR OFF
THE FRENCH COAST REALLY IS
KNOWN TO BE DRINK YOUNG
VIBRANT FRUIT FORWARD STITCHES
FORWARD SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
ENJOY A HOT DAY CHEERS, LET'S
CUT TO THE IT'S DEFINITELY A
HOT DAY TODAY. AND THIS THIS
IS WHERE ACTUALLY POURING WE
HAVE A ROSE DAY EVERY DAY FOR
BRUNCH. AND THIS IS ONE OF OUR
OPTIONS TRULY IS ALL DAY. LET
ME ASK YOU A QUICK QUESTION I
KNOW WE ONLY HAVE A FEW
SECONDS LEFT BUT WITH THE
WHITES AND THE AND THE ROSES
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT YOU WANT
TO DRINK YOUNG YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU DON'T WANT THOSE
SITTING AROUND THEIR LOSS FOR
THEM FOR THE MOST PART THOSE
A'S YES FOR THE MOST PART
WHITES. YES, THERE'S A COUPLE
LIGHT WINDS A U.S. LED AGE BUT
FOR THE MOST PART YEAH
EVERYTHING IS MEANT TO BE
WANT TO JUST TALK ABOUT THE 2
OF YOU KNOW I HEAR IT'S A
SPECIAL DAY FOR SOMEONE IT IS
MY DAUGHTER SLOAN IS TURNING
11 TODAY, SO HAPPY BIRTHDAY
CHAIRS TO SLOAN, HAPPY
BIRTHDAY, AND IF YOU WANT TO
CHECK OUT THE DOUBLE YOU KNOW
IT'S A WEEKLY EVENT MONDAY'S
FROM FOR CAMP.